so what's going on with the alireza game  they are making repetition of moves or  is there something else going on  doesn't look like much has changed over  the last couple moves but it's not a  repetition no it's not repetition  could happen 27 okay 527 and fabian did  resign  what an epic battle between  the americans where  nakamura  controlled 98  of the game  had a very anxious moment in the opening  caron blitz the first 20 moves clearly  was familiar with this position still  where i would guess bishop g5 which is a  computer move would have led to some  sick variations  with fabi showing his homework with c4  nakamura instead also blitzing let's  start the move knight g3 i don't know if  this was homework  or just  improvisation  but then some fantastic moves we already  talked about at night h1 h4 the star  moves yeah and nakamura took complete  control